[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to fragment
tricks today we're going to be talking
about a few effective patterns for using
the fragment api's in your ass now some
of these are going to be they may seem a
little bit basic but there are also
things that are going to help you build
it apps in a way that factors your code
effectively encapsulate things and make
sure that you can keep your code clean
stupid fragment tricks yeah stupid
fragment tricks
anyway so let's start and start with a
little bit of history behind this which
kind of helps to understand where some
of the fragment api's came from so as we
started moving into large screen devices
it's a honeycomb era we started
realizing that there are a few specific
patterns in the way that some apps are
put together especially apps the time
you've got one area that's devoted to
your navigation and then you've got
another area that's devoted the content
and when you put these two things
together you can imagine on a small
screen device you might see the
navigation as one screen that advances
to a Content screen and when you're on a
larger screen device you're able to show
these same things side by side so we had
this question of how do you write an
apps that work seamlessly across both so
the fragment api's were born it was
something that you could use to factory
out your activity components into two
separate pieces that you could show
differently they some different device
configuration now this works really well
for some applications like Gmail but
your app probably isn't Gmail if you've
followed the development of app design
over the past several years you realize
that this sort of pattern just doesn't
fit for a lot of things however it's
still extremely useful for representing
your application as a series of
destinations so even on a small screen
device you might have an app that looks
something like this we've got our little
application that where you can order
some micro kitchen snacks around the
Google campus and for each one of these
screens you can perform a replace
transaction to replace the destination
that you're looking at previously with
the new one a replace transaction will
remove any fragment in the container and
then add the new fragment
so the nice thing about this is that you
can place these particular transactions
on the back sack and we'll go ahead and
handle that back navigation for you now
the nice thing about this is that the
content and navigation pane separation
isn't limited to just large screens this
can really help to keep your chrome
stable in your application so anytime
that you have things like bars net
drawers bottom navigation bars any of
these things that you want to keep
stable and performs some consistent
animations from one screen to another
this really lets you do it in the way
that is really difficult to accomplish
with activity to activity transitions
where you can't preserve that kind of
continuity in your UI as you navigate
deeper in your apps hierarchy a little
bit Madigan flows now when I talk about
navigation flows I'm talking about those
step by step flows that you have in your
application so when you have a checkout
or a signup or a set up wizard you're
going to go the users are going a step
by step through their navigation and
then they might want to wander back
using the back button or and then go
forward again and then when they're all
done you want to be all done with that
you don't want to want your user to be
able to go back through the checkout
process again at the back button that
was kind of stuck wouldn't it so we're
going to here focus on on our app the
micro kitchen app which we've been
trying to sell the Googlers to get to
sell them the free Mexican snacks it
hasn't been working very well it has not
but we know we have new customers coming
in this summer interns so we're pretty
sure that they will partake in our great
free Mexican service and when the user
comes in they're going to click on the
checkout on the cart button and what
we're going to do is we're going to
remove the little cart at the bottom
that little fragment there and then
we're also going to remove that big
replace that big fragment at the top
with our new fragment that we're going
to label cart not the fragment but we're
a label to the state cart and I'm going
to talk about that a little bit later
why we're giving it a name on the
backpack and then when they hit checkout
they can then choose the address they
want to ship to and we're just going to
replace that fragment with their address
selection one and they can get a twos
payment then and we replace it again
with a payment fragment and again it's
added in the back stack and this time we
don't we don't need a name for this back
stack space because we don't need well
we'll talk about it a little bit where
they can go back through the back stack
if they want the good navigate back and
choose a different address if they want
by hitting the back button and as
developers we don't have to do any other
work that that just pops that fragment
right back into our stake and it's great
and then the the user can go back
through choose the payment and then
confirm the purchase now here's the
confirmed purchase screen we're going to
do a couple things all at once we're
going to do a pop backpack all the way
back to that original cart state that we
said and because we passed the inclusive
flag there now it pops that heart state
also and it'll go all the way back pop
all those states back and then at the
same time we add this new transaction
which will replace that state with our
thank-you page because we want to thank
them for giving them giving us all their
money it's pretty good I mean they need
we need to thank them for giving us all
their money now on this one we have a
little different thing going on of the
ok button doesn't just create new
transaction it's going to pop the back
stack as well now no matter what the
user does it's going to the users going
to be the right thing they're not going
to add a new transaction add to that
that state we don't want to have that
thank-you page come back again if they
pop the back step so it's going to come
right back to where they can buy more
stuff from us so you can see some of the
keys here to backpack net management
always maintain your backpack going
forward it's so much easier to manage
your backpack if you choose the
direction your users going to go on the
back stack as you navigate forward don't
time the user presses the back button
choose what they're going to do it's a
lot harder to manage sort to take
advantage of this kind of thing
sometimes you need to do some synthetic
back tech management that means if you
have a an external link into your
application some kind of deep nested
thing they're selecting a particular
cart item and when they hit the back
button you don't want them to go to some
the main screen you want them to go into
the category of perhaps or even from a
notification or from a notification
that's a great example from the notation
or maybe a search inside your
application you might want to have the
same thing so what do we do well we just
execute a whole bunch of transactions
all at the same time so build up the
stack for them boo boo boo boo boo boom
execute them well hang on George so if I
make repeated transactions then that
means that each one of those
transactions I'm going to start and stop
those fragments as I execute each one in
turn so that that can be really
expensive right so how do I go ahead and
maintain that back stack state while
still not doing a whole lot of really
heavyweight work as I start and stop
each one of those fragments along the
way yeah that's a really big problem
because you have to create all those
views tear them down again inflation
right it seems like a lot of unnecessary
work it is a lot of unnecessary work
sorry guys
well you want to pick that sure all
right thanks Adam so now we have this
new thing here called set reordering
allows and what this does is it allows
all of the execution to happen all at
once without changing your fragment
state and then at the very end we bring
up all the fragments that need to be
brought up and tear down all the
fragment that need be torn down and now
your fragments don't have to go through
all that oh I got it removed okay I
don't remember so we can optimize this
for you but you have to watch out
because if you expected
a fragment to exist that didn't that
might have been optimized out if it you
expected it to go through this creation
it might not have done that
so you have to watch out for this so you
use this in your applications it's great
to use but expect some slightly
different behavior than before now you
might have seen in our in our
application that as a user click through
the checkout screen it was just oh hop
hop hop the screens changed
instantaneously and that's not very
pleasant so what we can do is we can add
transitions the easiest ones to use are
the trick the basic transistor
transitions that come with fragments and
there are three options and this is done
on the transaction you call set
transition and the basic transition
transitions are fade open and closed and
from this it's really hard to see the
differences but you can see the fade has
just a simple crossfade and the open and
close also have a fade and zoom so play
with it a little bit see what works well
in your application see what you like
that it provides a nice subtle effect
for your transition what if I want to do
something a little bit more in keeping
with my own apps design yeah if you want
something mobile custom then we can use
animations animations in this case is
the view animations that that allow you
to change scale rotation translation
alpha so fading so you can set those
four and this is only on the support
library you can set those on the view
coming in the act the fragment coming in
on a separate one for the fragment being
popped sorry being removed and also the
same thing for the top as well the ones
that being added and removed if you have
different animations for each of those
and you can get an effect like this
which is very nice a slide effect but
you couldn't do with the basic animation
biggest ranches transitions now if
you're working with the framework
fragments you can do the same things
with animators but they provide even
more benefit because now you can animate
any property on the view it means you
can have some really custom animations
whatever you want to do it's great and
what's better now you can also do that
in this world I break
[Applause]
transition style is also added for
Frankford framework so that you can do
this set your animations animators in a
style now a lot of you have been using
the activity transitions and you want to
have that work with fragments as well so
activity transitions allows this great
ability to have a shared element change
from one view to another so in this case
from one fragment to another and it
works on activity transitions from
lollipop on very useful and so we added
the ability to do that so in fragment
you call instead of doing this on the
transaction you do this on the fragment
itself you can set the views the
animations the transition to do on the
views that are coming in and this is for
all the views that are not the shared
element so that's the enter transition
and the shared element enter transition
this is the one you do on the view that
is moving this is our shared element in
this case I don't know what it was the
almonds maybe and here this move views
is a combination of change bounds change
transform and change image transform as
too many things to fit on the slide but
that's what it is here and then in the
transaction we add the shared element
itself and the shared element is the
view that's in that fragment and then we
have a target name this name this is a
shared element transition name and this
is the name that you've given the
transition element in the fragment that
has not been inflated yet so this in
this case it's in the my fragment that's
being pulled in and then we can have our
transition which is great but
something's wrong right
you see it everyone raised his hand if
you see it what's the problem with this
okay a lot of you can see the problem
right transition is only working one way
right it works great getting into the
into the detailed view but when we come
back to that main view with all those
other of these other elements you're not
seeing it and why is that well that main
view is a recycler view and what's
happening is the recycler view will lay
out its views after the set adapter call
is made so we have to wait for the
layout call after the Civet after result
is made and the transition is coming in
and said hey I want to share element and
it's not there so what does it do says
up give up fade-out
and so in activity transitions what do
we do well it's great we have this thing
called postponing the transaction we're
postponing the transition so we have a
postpone enter transition and then we
when the views are ready we call start
postpone gender transition so it gives
you all the ability to say okay just
hold on a second wait for my views come
on come on views come on views and then
state when they're all ready then you
said go and so we want to do this for
fragments as well so here we go we can
do it for fragments but there's one
extra thing you need to do you
absolutely have to have the set
reordering allowed because for our short
time while you're postponing both
fragments are there they're both active
and that is not the order you've set is
it you expected one to be removed
another one be added so both those views
for both fragments are creating they
created state so that's gonna be a
little weird for you so we want to make
sure that you know that you're getting
into this situation so let's see how
it's done in our application in my on
create view now you can do this anytime
before on create on preview so if you
wanted to you can do it not create
whatever you want to do you call
postpone under transition because I
at this point I am going to do a
recyclerview and I know I need to worry
about the transitions there and because
I love data binding some of you might
know that I love data binding and we
have a few models here too so that's
good too mm-hmm Thank You Adam if you
haven't seen that talk you should go
back and watch it we're using that so
here I'm setting the setting the adapter
for my recycle review now I'm setting my
adapter now I have to wait for the
layout so I'm waiting for the layout and
then that listener I call start
postponed enter transition now my
transition is ready and it will just go
on ahead and I figure I stick to slide
so okay it works all right so one of the
other features moving along to something
completely different one of the other
features that we get a lot of questions
about are the set retain instance method
on fragments so you retain an instance
across an activity destruction and
creation across something like a
configuration change so this means that
the object instance itself of the
fragment that you've marked this way is
transferred across the parent recreation
so anything that you put there is moved
along with it so objects you don't have
to serialize this into a partial bowl
passed across as shared as saved in some
state but the important thing to
remember if you're doing this is that it
doesn't happen if the process is
recreated your objects aren't there so
you need to be a little bit careful
about this you need to make sure that
you can still restore from instance
state if you have to even though in the
common case you still have the full
objects that you may have created in the
first place so this is a replacement for
the old on retained non configuration
instance method that was on activity in
fact the same mechanism is used to
implement the fragments version of this
but what's a little bit more interesting
is that this mechanism is right now the
backbone of the dn't view model
component that we've been talking about
earlier at i/o here so the view models
are actually saved within a
retain instance fragments to shuffle
them across from one one activity of the
next and this just kind of goes to show
the types of infrastructure that you can
build on top of a routine instance
fragment it's something that's a little
bit on the more abstract end of things
so we end up getting a lot of questions
about hey what's this good for oh this
is a pretty good example and just like
we talked about with view models it
means that there's a few things that you
really need to avoid in this case
don't put views in a retain instance
fragment unless you want to do a lot of
manual bookkeeping technically you can
kind of get away with it if you're
really careful make sure that you
release all your references and
ondestroy view of that particular
fragment so on and so forth but really
it ends up being best just to kind of
avoid it and we'll get into a few more
patterns later in the talk here around
what you can do instead context
specifically activity context well we
all know why you don't want to save an
instance of an activity longer than the
lifetime of that activity itself but the
thing that really tends to catch people
is callback references so if you
register a listener or some sort of a
callback with a fragment and that
fragment is going to outlive the
container it's really easy to
accidentally close over that in that
context that you had and have the
activity still outlast the original host
so child fragments are something that
did a lot of people really hard a few
years ago because frankly we had a lot
of bugs around them and they were
created to solve a particular problem
and that was dependency management
within a particular activity so consider
this case you've got a fragment that has
a viewpager
pretty common right the viewpager uses a
fragment pager adapter because that's a
pretty easy way to use a view pager and
then you remove the pager fragment well
now we have a problem so what actually
happens in that case you've got all the
fragments that were added by the pager
adapter but the host fragment or the
conceptual host fragment in this case
that has a view pager itself was removed
now something has to be in charge of
removing the individual page fragments
and this was something that really kind
of went to show that a single collection
of fragments is insufficient in fact
when the fragment api's were first sort
of rolling out to a lot of internal
developers right around honeycomb this
is
of the first questions that we got and
it took us quite a while to come back
and address this of what happens when
you do have these dependencies in
between fragments and part of the reason
why this was such a pain is because we
didn't have any ordering guarantees
around fragments being created and
what's worse is a lot of times this only
would come up much much later in the
process just because you added fragments
in one particular order you could
control that that order as you're
running that and kind of running the
initial transactions that builds up that
state but when your process dies and we
restore those fragments from instant
state later the order of that recreation
was always undefined depending on what
all may have happened throughout the
lifetime of your activity before just
kind of due to some artifacts of
internal bookkeeping this was something
that could cause these things to be
reordered in terms of which one would
get oncreate first so on and so forth
and it made it very difficult to
reconnect any sorts of shared State now
this sort of shared state is something
that's much easier to handle with the
viewmodel system that we showed earlier
but at the time we really didn't have a
good solution to this problem so one of
the other things that was kind of a pain
is that the deferred transaction commits
that have been common ever since we are
up until we added the commit now method
on fragment transaction the nice thing
and the reason why this was done in the
first place was to avoid reentrant calls
you didn't have to worry about one
particular transaction being half
executed and then starting another
transaction as a result of it but this
really did have a cost and I think that
if you're in this room right now you've
probably experienced some of the costs
of this raise your hand if you called
execute pending transactions to fix a
bug yeah that's a lot of hands so this
is one of those things that ends up
being really kind of difficult to work
with so child fragments as dependencies
work out really well because they solve
a lot of these particular issues it's a
separate fragment manager so you don't
get the reentrant cases no matter what
if you go ahead and use commit now on a
bunch of these things you don't have to
worry about your parent being in a
potentially inconsistent state as you do
this because you're all working within
your own local units
so all these things are added and
removed as a unit which means that it
solves that viewpager problem it means
that if you remove the containing
fragment then you don't have to care
about the implementation details of that
fragment well this kind of seems like
one of those duh things in hindsight and
it's all guaranteed to be restored after
a called the super dot on create this is
also important because now you can rely
on when these things have actually been
restored you don't have to worry about
these ordering things that are out of
your control but perhaps most
importantly the implementation details
again don't leak into your surrounding
containers so in conclusion many of you
may have run into a lot of particular
issues around child fragments please
don't try version 26 we have fixed more
and more issues around this specifically
around inflating child fragments this is
one of my favorite uses of this we
talked earlier about using fragments as
very coarse-grained destinations within
your application something that takes up
an entire UI pane of your app but
nesting within other fragments even if
you inflate them from one of these
coarser grain navigation destinations it
just kind of works like you don't have
to worry about taking care of all these
other sort of nested lifecycle issues
and it lets you build smarter
encapsulated components I mean we always
kind of get this question - I mean like
hey do I build a via group do I build a
fragment and there's been a lot of ink
spilled and keyboard smashed making
these particular arguments online I
never know what to do with this hmm I
never know what to do do i building a
new group or a fragment right so I spell
people that just use egos exactly so you
know excuse me Adam you said that
crossing the streams was bad so the rule
of thumb for this is essentially as
follows view should really only be
responsible for displaying information
and publishing direct user interaction
events these end up being very low-level
events like button was clicked user
scrolled something these these are
responsible for drawing text and these
other sorts of operations that are user
interaction whereas fragments integrate
with the surrounding life site
and they may be aware of other app
components this is really what gives
context to everything that you're doing
in your UI so you might bind to a
service you might be communicating with
your app's data model for forming a
database query so on and so forth so you
should never use a fragment when a view
will do but you also wanna make sure
that you're not adding outside
dependencies to your views it's
definitely a code smell if you ever find
yourself doing something like trying to
bind to a service from a view
implementation or trying to make a
network call or again trying to
integrate with anything that's outside
of the realm of just that one individual
view but that means that there's a whole
it means that you can't build just
something that simple is like a
completely self-contained like button
but you can just stick right in the
middle of one of your layouts and treat
it as fire-and-forget give it some
parameters and go well this is one of
the reasons why you can inflate
fragments in this case we're showing
that you can define parameters to these
you can place in line we can go ahead
and inflate arguments in a way that
excuse me in a way that allows you to do
this without having a lot of very
heavyweight integration you don't have
to go find it
configure it separately you just do it
inline so one of the things that made
this really difficult to do in the past
was kind of again just artifact of
history and they you couldn't actually
set fragment arguments that arguments
bundle after after the fragment had been
added to a fragment manager so now we've
relaxed that and we've said that now
fragment arguments can be changed
anytime the state isn't saved including
during inflation so there's this case
where after you rotate or so on and so
forth and we're reconnecting inflated
fragments which is again something that
we do automatically then you can run in
this case where we've already restored
that fragment
we're trying to hook it back up again
but it's already added which means that
you can't do what the natural thing is
which is to represent all those
arguments that you may inflate as
arguments in the bundle so that way you
have basically a single source of truth
for all the configuration parameters of
that fragment well now you can way to
take any wave in here go back go back
what does not is state safe thing oh
yeah so again a bunch of people had I
don't know where this comes from but
people apparently try to commit fragment
transactions when states already been
saved and they've got why would you do
that I don't know but because I can't
tell that might have been it yeah so we
added a simple getter on this one so
that you can know when that happens and
it also makes things like writing
lifecycle aware components that make
sure that you don't try to crack mint
transactions when when it's not valid to
do so I was a whole heck of a lot easier
thank you so again part of what we're
trying to do here is create a much
better layered infrastructure we've
traditionally hidden a lot of these
internals in some of these Android
components such that only the internal
components are twiddling them which
means that as soon as you all have a
more complicated case that you're trying
to handle we've made it very difficult
for you to do this in the past so we
tried to open a lot more of those things
up make these things a little bit easier
to inspect from your own code to deal
with those cases that arise that we
didn't think of so in this case the
pattern that we really kind of want to
encourage is mapping fragment arguments
to attributes for those UI fragments
again it gives you kind of a single
source of truth so let's go ahead and go
over to an example of this so in this
case we've got a few kind of nice little
Kotlin based methods that are extensions
that make this a little bit easier to
handle in this case we've got one
utility method that is just our width
styled attributes here so many of you
have dealt with inflating attributes for
views and you know you have to get the
typed array you have to recycle it
afterwards it's really easy to just kind
of wrap these up inside some extension
functions similarly we have this this
simple little thing hey is there a
bundle there for arguments already if so
reuse it otherwise create a new one so
these are the sorts of things that
Kotlin really adds to the fragment API
all the things that are kind of a pain
in the neck to do with fragments you can
make some simple extensions that you
were really hard to do before
but for example one of my favorite
features for something like this is to
use property delegates to deal with
arguments and you can rap even more of
this stuff and just basically treat them
as normal properties on your fragment
objects so putting a bunch of this
together
fragments help you maintain more of a
content and chroma separation they give
you the ability to keep your content
pages as fully encapsulated items
without disturbing the rest of the UI
around it you get richer transitions you
get better shared components because you
can reuse a lot of these things and you
don't have to initialize all of them
separately and you can better
encapsulate your dependencies so you
don't necessarily have to leak all of
these things to the surrounding host and
thank you very much for coming
[Music]